big news this morning about that single  dose johnson johnson coronavirus vaccine  new studies found booster doses of the j  j shot generated a rapid and robust  nine-fold spike in antibodies which is  good it's now submitting that data to  the federal government  officials hope this could push holdouts  to get the shot  the unvaccinated people are spreading  delta so fast that they are basically  bathing the vaccinated people in delta  exposures and that's a little bit more  than what our vaccines were really  developed to be able to handle  moderna is asking the fda for full  approval of its vaccine pfizer got that  full approval earlier this week about  half of eligible americans are  vaccinated against the coronavirus